hey everybody it's Chris Harrison host
of The Bachelor presents listen to your
heart I'm joining BuzzFeed today to read
your thirst tweets see how this goes
petition to make Chris Harris send the
next Bachelor and have him dramatically
announce his own final rose at the rose
ceremonies and that is if I were to ever
be the bachelor which I will not be I
will be hosting my own show my own
one-on-one talks my own rose ceremonies
it will be dramatic and sad whenever
people have the who's the hottest Chris
debate why do they always exclude Chris
Harrison geez have you seen Chris
Hemsworth have you seen Chris Evans
I so wish Chris Harrison would take me
on a one-on-one date it would be the
most dramatic one-on-one day ever you
know I would probably not get the rose
I'm about to say it I want to take Chris
Harrison to the fantasy suite
all right well see how that goes when I
give myself the fantasy suite card where
I would write it myself and then give it
to myself on the day that seems
self-serving I picked you Chris Harrison
will you marry me
seems forward we haven't met don't know
you but in these Florentine times you
know what what the hell okay I'm just
gonna say it I want Chris Harrison to be
my sugar daddy like that I liked it
we've gotten right to it we don't want a
real relationship you just want to use
me and I'm fine with that if you're up
front and you're honest about it
I'm good with that Chris Harrison with a
beard can't get it hashtag Bachelor
Winter Games that was the one time
during the Winter Games I thought you
know what we're in the wild it's winter
snow I'm gonna have some scruff so thank
you for those that appreciated my beard
Chris Harrison is really just sexy Jerry
Springer yeah you know this last season
with Peter I felt like I was just a
chair throw away from Jerry Springer so
as that might be more on point than I
hope Chris Harrison
choked me out challenge I think Noah ten
means
okay pretty sure everyone already knows
what goes on in the fantasy suite
threesome with Chris Harrison a that
hasn't happened B that never even really
crossed my mind yeah but if you're into
it nay whatever whatever floats your
boat
my boyfriend is mad that I would let
Chris Harrison spit in my mouth oh wow
like a little bird feeding you that's
that scenes that seems harsh aggressive
is Chris Harrison aware that bachelor
nation refers to him as daddy Chris
Harrison
yes sometimes I think Demi may have
started that especially to Chris
Harrison hey daddy please you know what
me hard moving on
Chris Harrison will you accept this
insert the body part you want right
there so that's it guys
those are the thirsty tweets thanks
BuzzFeed for having me enjoy listen to
your heart guys
you